despite the weather and steep prices for
gasoline tens of millions of americans
are expected to head out this holiday
weekend according to aaa more than 39
million people will travel 50 miles or
more that's up more than 8 percent over
last year and it comes as the cost of
filling up the tank is at record high
prices nationwide a gallon of regular
costs four dollars sixty cents that is
51 percent higher than last year michael
george is here with more michael good
morning dana good morning just think
about this gas jumped up another 50
cents just in the last month and the
timing couldn't be worse but so far the
sky high prices don't seem to be
stopping people from hitting the road
this memorial day weekend
with the pandemic in their rear-view
mirrors americans are on the road again
and they're choosing to head right into
the glare of higher costs that they're
willing to drive with these high gas
prices i mean gas prices are a dollar 61
more than they were memorial day 2019.
that's you know 24 dollars more when you
fill up a car every time you fill up a
car
that's a lot they're shunning mass
transportation
ridership is half of what it was before
the pandemic you still got to live life
so you got to spend a little bit more
money diversions to air travel won't
land passengers in bargain territory
according to the american automobile
association airfares are up six percent
hotel rates are up 42 percent people
know that hotel prices are high and yet
bookings are high so everybody is
telling us that you know we know that
it's going to be more expensive but we
want to go
and going right along for the ride are
state tourism campaigns north dakota's
6.5 million dollar tourism campaign
drove two million visitors to its
website hawaii's tourism authority is
promoting a new urban trail and kansas
awarded 11 tourism grants to develop
attractions
while americans are showing they're
willing to spend for leisure travel some
say they found other ways to cut costs
probably cut our driving plans maybe
mileage-wise in half prices are
skyrocketing so if i any way i can kind
of pinch the pennies if you will to
to like to keep the rest in the bank
they may have slightly altered their
day-to-day lifestyle
when it comes to actually going on
vacation they've budgeted in for that
and they've decided i'm going to pay the
price because for me getting from point
a to point b
paying gas it may be still cheaper than
paying for an airfare and paying for a
hotel and paying for a rental car
and air travelers may also be having a
tough start to the holiday weekend
according to flightaware more than
twelve hundred flights were canceled
yesterday that's mostly due to the
weather and ongoing staffing problems at
the airlines jeff family experience
those flight delays as well michael
thank you very much